OSKAR: So there are a few things
we need to have in mind.
JEFF: Okay.
OSKAR: Before we go in.
So we can see
like the roof here.
JEFF: Yeah.
OSKAR: How thin it is.
And this part can
collapse and it does.
And then inside the ice cave,
you can hear the running water?
JEFF: I can.
OSKAR: You have
to mind the river.
JEFF: Okay.
OSKAR: We don't want
to fall in the river.
So one for you, my friend.
JEFF: Thank you, my friend.
Good?
OSKAR: Looking good.
JEFF: I like it.
OSKAR: Let's go.
JEFF: Let's do it.
You can hear rocks falling.
There's so much
water just rushing down.
You could just hear pieces of
ice just like falling and, and
it was cracking.
It was actually a lot
louder than I thought.
I am nervous this
could collapse on me.
But here's the thing.
I've had to overcome so
much just to get here.
I can't let my
fears stop me now.
Oh.
Oh-ho-ho.
This is incredible.
I can't believe how big it is.
OSKAR: It's huge.
JEFF: This is massive.
As I walked through the entrance
and made it past the darkness,
there's just this
massive opening and
walls of just light
turquoise, kind of blue.
It's glacier blue.
That's what I'm
gonna keep calling it.
Glacier blue sounds great.
To be down here to see the
blue, it's just beautiful.
And this is a moulin?
OSKAR: This is a moulin.
JEFF: And I love it.
It just...
It just continues to look like
somebody like chiseled away.
I've never seen ice this big.
Seeing the ice shaped in all
these crystal-like sculptures
is amazing.
Growing up in Florida,
I never thought I would
see something like this.
I'm so excited that
we actually found one.
Really am.
After climbing a glacier,
hiking for miles and
crossing a icy lagoon, to be
here right now is so worth it.
♪ We found a ice cave ♪
Yes.